so guys incredible days did you do it
you did it yourself I was so full of
adrenaline at the time and I was so
happy I finally done it
come on he's super cute it's incredible
[Music]
take us through your favorite body mods
and tattoos it would be my mic that's my
first mods that's pretty special
yeah like what got me into it what did
your parents think we look so young at
the time you know they didn't mind I
think my mum could my mum can't look at
it my dad kind of fascinated by it as
long as I'm safe he doesn't even mind
what I do as long as I'm safe since I
was about I suppose 14 13 14 soon as
adolescence kicked in I was always
wanted to to change my appearance sort
of from fact the world and [ __ ] perv
and sort of thing it was just the
continuation of that was when I was 17
got a lot of bad tattoos I've got worse
I've got some kiss I've got monster
monster magnet I've got heavy metal
written there Black Sabbath fear they
mean me Jesus on one eyelid and Satan on
the other not because I believed in any
of them I don't believe any of it exists
you know you might think he's already
just to me I don't care cuz it's because
I'm making everything's anyway what
about some of guys incredible days did
you do it you did it yourself what did
it feel like with the masses so many
times when the actual adrenaline at the
time I was so happy I finally done it
and I know the types of I love it I love
it it's it is incredible scarification
I've had like a Y section like an
autopsy Y cut I see the beginnings of it
just yeah I've got the scarification
they're saying as you go I've got I've
got it on my got it on my face epic
such a lot of tattoo what you can't see
it but at the time when I first got it
done it was like yours the red it was
all bright red photographs of that
because I really liked it when it was
bloody and really yeah I guess I did
eventually I've had branding I have a
whole Astrid it just says writing theme
help me that was sucky
beyond DubLi I couldn't sit down for so
long I though he's never doing things I
find it's never getting this happy we're
getting them what it's always the
healing yes what are some of the common
misconceptions people have about you
total lunatic not very intelligent
violent I think they think I'll be
violent they probably think I was single
which I'm not I'm married with children
and I'm doubt if they think that did
they certainly wouldn't think I'm a next
civil servant the last few years of my
career if you want to call you that
nobody on my section the talk to me at
all can go down a record and saying and
nobody would speak to me I used to sit
there and if I didn't start a
conversation up with somebody
nobody would start conversation out with
me no I was like I provide here Wow yeah
what about you doing think they think of
you everyone is lovely in person and I'm
sure it's like with everyone and the
internet however I still maintain I've
had more marriage proposals and death
threats so I think all right and the
other thing is like a lot of the stuff
they've they've heard about me or soon
it's only part truth yes I have done
certain things but then there don't you
know publications and makeup different
things
tell me about it as well they're
thinking I've you know I'm this person
and actually I'm only I'm only a little
bit like that it doesn't make me who I
am it doesn't you know affect how I I
treat people with everyday life or
anything you know is the people are so
shocked by likes of us aren't they it's
crazy yeah but that's partly why we do I
supposed to a point as well if somebody
said would you like to swap the way you
look for a really macho but like really
that really great sculptured body with
the six-pack but you wouldn't have any
tattoos would you have swap it I'd say
no but it wouldn't mean anything to me
I'd rather have the tattoos how those
really sculpted people that they their
their body is modified as well like what
are you doing really good for your body
I don't think it's sort of I do like the
attention and I am very very different I
know I'm very different it's like like
we're in the inside-outside sort of
thing so I feel like this is the real me
because I'm like screaming out look at
all this so really this is just what
I've feeling on the inside I just put
outside is there anything you wouldn't
do IT what I wouldn't do i wouldn't get
my tattoos these be actual the actual
whites of the eyes I think it looks
fantastic if I was to do it it would be
black I know what I'm having it's too
dangerous
I promised my dad that way it's just
that step too far
how do you feel seeing pictures of
yourself before any body mods don't mind
seeing him before body mods don't prefer
myself afterwards I don't like the way I
looked before I'd much prefer the way I
look now but this summer that I just
surrendered I think to myself just just
like another person just isn't me at all
especially my wedding photographs is
absolutely absolutely terrible yeah I
wonder how I could have walked around
looking like I did you know funny enough
I didn't like I felt every time I got
something else I was like oh I feel a
bit more like me now have you got any
when you were a teenager before your
heads I got a couple my picture taken
[Music]
[Laughter]
how would your appearance affected your
love life that's a good one I didn't
look like this before I met my wife but
she's still with me so it hasn't
affected it yeah I suppose but I suppose
it has in a way that he doesn't like me
about you see borbon he would do but
didn't happen it depends how you want to
look at it but no not really
well if anything
they helped in general like well if your
modified and you're doing this that
gives you the confidence to be you and
just you know and if you're walking
around the confidence that's what
attracted to should body modification
procedures be treated like getting a
tattoo in up to tattoo parlor no I do
believe it needs to be a lot more
regulated and to stop Cowboys I'm going
to go people it's not regulated at all
that I know of and there are people I
think that you know they're going to to
get these modifications done where the
person is not qualified to do it
whatsoever I mean a lot of my education
I do myself is part of it for me that I
argue it I'm experimenting with my body
and that's what I will do not say I
haven't obviously gone to professionals
and which I suggest everybody else you
there's law gray areas around what can
and can't be done like well tattoos is
one thing in like scarifications another
amputation gets greater and gray you
know like someone's like oh you know
well it's my body I want me leg chopped
off you know where do you yeah I think
that's what the government are sort of
like weary of affection II sort of like
to see see
seen to condone something like that seem
to condone something they don't feel is
is anybody should be happy be able to
say why can't you
why can I go and get breast implants and
butt implants but I I'm gonna get told
off if I want like my belly button
removed or we should be allowed to do
that yeah have you seen a change in
people's attitudes towards you it goes
from one extreme to other than people
who absolutely hate it that that I mean
I get people looking to me look angry
that I've actually had done this to
myself they look angry at me that I've
done this even though it's not on them
really you will you know really bare
looks everything from that to laughing
at me I'll get that to just staring and
pointing them without you know oh my god
disgust I think you've got what the
other we scream the people that will
that will say they love you you know and
all this social media stuff I mean love
you
we scrap you know do you see people
taking pictures of you and oh yeah yeah
yeah
long as they say can you look they never
want it when I'm in habit yeah what
would you say to someone getting into
body modding do you research 100% do you
research make sure you know you
definitely want it done and then once
you know those two things go for it it's
brilliant
[Music]
yes it's a good web or do it for you yes
you've got a game to tattoo him get
tattoo it I think do it like this and
get the whole thing done and go crazy or
don't bother at all because there's so
many people getting tattooed now if you
just get an all know these hots to
tattoo your mother not bother to get it
guy that I don't think anybody notices
cares anymore he went in and ironically
enough the table next to ours was $0.50
and in the back there was Kanye West's
fiancee had $0.50 passed me a bottle of
vodka and that yeah it was crazy